pour survivre parmi les grands de
l'aviation commerciale air france vient
d'aménager à roissy une plate forme de
correspondances permettant des
changements ultra rapide d'un avion à
l'autre toutes les grandes compagnies
procède à ce type d'aménagement il faut
savoir qu'à roissy par exemple le rythme
des atterrissages et décollages s'est
accéléré on en est à un avion toutes les
90 secondes pascal golomer philippe
chasselas vous êtes chez air france à
roissy au poste de commandement s'il ya
un problème avec un avion un passager un
bagage c'est ici qu'on doit trouver très
vite une solution aujourd'hui n'ont
qu'un mot à la bouche
hubartus89 ça vous fait peur alors ça
nous fait pas peur
traduisez plate-forme de correspondance
ou plaque tournante en fait à partir de
demain matin toutes les lignes aériennes
d'air france seront organisées pour
offrir un maximum de correspondance à
roissy en un minimum de temps
ça paraît simple mais il faut adapter
les horaires faciliter le transfert des
passagers et des bagages aux heures de
pointe
éviter les retards surtout de longs mois
de préparation mais un choix vital pour
la compagnie les aéroports européens où
il y a
en 95 ont augmenté leur chiffre
d'affaires d'environ 6% à charles de
gaulle où il n'y a pas de pub nous avons
régressé de 0 5% preuve synonyme de
survie donc pour air france mieux qu'à
paris c'est à francfort comprend
l'intérêt de l'opération l'allemagne 83
millions d'habitants beaucoup d'hommes
d'affaires qui voyagent et qui paient
cher pour gagner du temps une clientèle
qu'air france compte séduire justement
grâce à de très bonnes correspondances
dès lundi passagers vont loin de munich
africains vont apparaître les
différentes possibles correspondance
classés par ordre de rapidité et donc
pour le client la meilleure solution
pour aller de munich à pékin dès lundi
c'est de passer par paris
être le plus rapide être en tête sur
l'écran informatiques dans les agences
de voyages ça peut rapporter gros
un milliard de francs supplémentaires
par an c'est l'objectif d'air france
la concurrence est rude toutes les
grandes compagnies européennes et
américaines ont déjà leurs hubs en tout
cas air france pourra désormais se
battre à armes égales